[Music]
New York Times bestselling author yes
good for you yeah that's fantastic
[Applause]
you get a massive massive book tour you
went all over the country Glee fans are
so rabid it must have been intense
because when you do a book tour you're
you're sitting at a desk they come right
up and they talk to you
Glee fans must have gone nuts yeah yeah
we were I was in the eye of the storm it
was it was crazy like everywhere I went
like they'd have to call the police for
crowd control yeah no it was great
amazing amazing fans but there are some
very interesting ones that does anyone
stand out as being a little eccentric on
that well one that does stand out was
there was a little girl very very pretty
little girl who came up and spoke
dolphin to me don't think yes she spoken
dolphin but but I didn't know what she
was saying but I think she was
disappointed that I didn't speak dolphin
as well yeah you came up to you and she
just started making doleful I'm not a
pro but it was something them like
something yeah so so I asked her I said
oh how do you say buy my book in dolphin
right and she she said Mannino she
wasn't choking to death magic the ass
you thought she was speaking a dolphin
how great you're talking about poor
thing well people wherever you go they
give you gifts don't they fans give you
gifts yes what I mean total champagne
problem but ya know and I made the
mistake a few years back saying that my
favorite animal was a llama because I've
always somehow related to a llama you
know like like when the llama is on a
farm where does it go you know it's not
a cow it's not a horse it's not a duck
or a chicken it just kind of grazes
around right I was like that was me in
high school it's kind of grazed around
and belonged anything so since then I I
swear I've gotten at least a hundred
thousand llamas stuffed llamas figurines
Miss fans read the article they heard
that quote and then they give you llamas
they give you well I have a rule I have
a huge wife several Amish elfs at my
house so it don't weigh all right
that's what you do in Hollywood first
thing when you get here Allah Michele
I'm not sure if it's punctuate I don't
know um but I so I have I have a llama
shelf and if I get one that's unique and
I don't have one already I'll put it on
the shelf all right we have a photo with
your llama shelf this is from your home
right here yes and that's just yeah
that's one yeah I got very creepy if I
broke into your house and I saw that I
didn't know who you were I broke into
the house and I saw those shelves I'd be
murdered right afterwards oh they'll
just they'll they'll like turn their
heads and look at you you're very
serious about this llama thing is that
correct well I was still pointing I
think it's gotten out of hand but but
I'm not helping myself because this year
I've already decided that my Halloween
costume is going to be a llama you're
gonna be a llama for Halloween
well I'm going to be a llama assassin
called the llama nadir you've been
talking to too many dolphins I think
you're starting to lose grasp of reality
you're going to be a character called
the llama named vomit yes and and and
you have you just tell us what the
costume has been a consistent well I
have a sketch I think because I take
howling very seriously so so yes you
basically think like Tom Cruise Mission
Impossible but a llama that's not what
I'm getting from that talking
let's make a ransom note what what do
you do what's going on with the eyes is
that a llama head so it's a guy with a
llama head and lumberjack boot yes